a lot of innovation involves taking
ideas from different areas of life and
kind of combining them in new ways and
that's a very powerful way to innovate
in fact it's probably the main way in
which people innovate and some of the
most powerful innovations that we've
actually seen in the world are ones that
kind of take ideas from areas that
people don't think are related to each
other and put them together in a really
an insightful way and entrepreneurs and
and and firms can really benefit from
being able to do that but but it raises
an interesting puzzle right or an
interesting challenge really which is
when you do that you then have to can
try to explain to people what this is
and what you're doing when you're
borrowing from those different
categories or you're taking ideas from
different domains so you're taking an
idea from biology and you're combining
it with an idea from computer science so
let's say now you have this kind of
hybrid product that's kind of mixed of
these two different things and the
problem is that people the rest of the
world doesn't think about the hybrids
they think about things in terms of the
existing categories and so we think
about firms as being auto manufacturers
and we think about firms as being you
know telephone manufacturers right or
something like that and a good example
is a product like a digital camera right
when digital cameras first came out
digital cameras are kind of a
combination of a computer an electronics
device and a camera right like a film
camera with the lens and so on and so
forth that poses a challenge for for
stakeholders for for consumers for for
investors and for others because how do
you make sense of of that so when you
first see a digital camera is it an
example of a camera or is it an example
of an electronics device or is it an
example of a computer peripheral and a
lot of what my work looks at is kind of
trying to understand how that ambiguity
that's inherent and kind of in a genuine
genuinely innovative new
product affects the strategies and kind
of the the the success of firms the
people can't kind of classify products
or services in do things that they
already understand then they have to
engage in kind of effortful reasoning to
make sense of them right and to try to
understand what they're doing and the
more you have to do that it actually
turns out the less you are likely to
value it right like the we tend to value
things the more the easier it is for us
to recognize what it is that they are
and so the challenge for for innovators
and for entrepreneurs is to find a way
to help make it easy for people to make
sense of the product innovation that you
have come up with and oftentimes the way
they do that is through analogy so we
use the power of analogy as a way of
getting people to anchor on a certain
set of expectations and then use that to
interpret the new device right so we say
wow the iPhone is like a cell phone
except that it also has the following
features we say that a digital camera is
like a camera but it also has the
following features and by doing that we
on the one hand invoke a lot of
associations that are really helpful but
we can also constrain ourselves in
different kinds of ways because we might
end up with associations with our
product that we don't necessarily want
it also creates a really hard strategic
challenge for the company because you
because you're choosing from lots of
different categories you have different
choices in terms of what analogy you're
going to draw are you gonna say it's
more like this category or you more more
like that category
obviously what's hard about that when
you're in a new product category in your
new innovative category is for the
entrepreneurs you don't know which one
you're supposed to put your bets on and
so that feels really risky but that
doesn't mean that you shouldn't do it
right that you still have to make a bet
and so you have to kind of take what
your best guess is for what the right
analogy is because otherwise you just
end up as a model and then nobody can
really make sense of it and you they
tend to devalue you for that reason so
if you're a big established company then
people try to look at that product then
they say oh this must somehow be related
to what they already do and that puts
our constraint on kind of how people
make sense of it and therefore affects
your ability to be innovative I think a
good example comes from the realm of
digital cameras so when digital cameras
were first introduced
what you saw was producers from all
different kinds of industries in
particular you saw the traditional film
camera producers enter into the market
and start making digital cameras so you
saw the Nikon and the canons and so on
and so forth but you also saw computer
companies come in so you saw HP make
digital cameras and you saw electronics
firms like Sony or Panasonic come into
the digital camera business as well and
one of the things that my research shows
is it kind of early in the history of
the industry you were actually better
off in terms of how consumers thought
about the quality of your product if you
were a producer who had a history of
making film cameras and my understanding
of that or the way I explain that is
that really what that is about is about
what kind of mental models they apply to
the product that they saw and so that if
you saw a digital camera that was made
by Hewlett Packard you tended to
interpret that through the lens of what
a computer peripheral manufacturer would
make or computer manufacturer would make
and that set your expectations for what
the product could have couldn't do while
if you were coming at it from the lens
and you're looking at a product that
Nikon had made then your expectations
are shaped by what a traditional camera
menu
what was was able to do and those things
make a big difference and so I think the
lesson for large firms is that really
your existing identity in the market
like the kinds of products and services
that you're known for can really
restrict your ability to introduce new
new products into the market if they're
genuinely innovative and genuinely
different from what you already know how
to do that doesn't mean you can't
introduce them but you have to do it in
a different way because if if you do it
kind of under your own brand name then
people get started to invoke those
associations with your existing products
and that might not be the best way to
actually go I think startups have a have
a big advantage in the sense that they
don't have the the legacy of the past or
the burden of the past right so so a
start-up comes on the scene with a new
technology nobody has an association
with any existing set of products so on
the one hand that's a that's a that's a
liability because you got to build up a
reputation you got to kind of establish
what kind of product it is and and so on
and so forth but it can also be an
advantage because you have more degrees
of freedom you have more latitude to
choose how it is that you want to
portray what it is that you're actually
producing and what the value of your
product is
I think entrepreneurs and innovators
oftentimes think about the the hard part
being the technical side of the
innovation right so how do I really get
those components to work together in the
way that I have imagined that they will
and there's no doubt that the technical
side of it is really important but we we
have to not lose sight of the social
side of it as well right and kind of the
the external facing how is it that
people are going to make sense of your
product relative to all the other
products that exist out there in the
world and that's a very hard part of it
as well and the really successful
entrepreneurs are going to be the ones
who solve both the technical problem and
the market identity problem